BACK IN.
SO HE IS IN.
IT'S MIKE SMITH FOR THE EDMONTON
OILERS.>> Jack: 16 YEARS A MEMBF
THE CHICAGO BLACKHAWKS.
DUNCAN KEITH CAME OVER
FIRST GAME.
BUT -- EDMONTON BEAT -- BUTK.
HE AVERAGES
ACROSS.
NO LOOKER.
THAT WAS TAPE TO TAPE AND
DeBRINCAT ALWAYS HAS TIPPETT HAN
THEER BY DACH.
HE KNOWS THAT DeBRI IN GOALS SC.
AND 25th IN GOALS
HERE'S PATRICK KANE LOADING,
DISHING, BROKEKEN FRONT.
ONE-TIMER!
WHAT A SAVE BY SMITH!
THAT'S THE ONEOTENTIAL ODD-MAN
RUSH.
>> Louie: THAT WAS A TWO ON
ONE.
YOU'RE RIGHT, JACK.
JUST A LME OFFENSIVELY AND THAT.
EVANDER KANE SWARMED UNDER BY
THE ROOKIE. BY MUCH.
NICE JOB BY LAFFERTY TO GET A
PIECE OF IT. SWITCH IT UP.
BIT OFRT MAKING BETTER
PLAYS WITH THE PUCK.
>> Jack: EXCUSE ME, PARTN CHICAO
BLACKHAWKS OBVIOUSLY 17 -- 1
McDAVID, BUILDING SPEED.
LOOKS FOR TMARC-ANDRE
FLEURY TO STAY WITH
LAFFERTY.
>> Louie: EXC OILERS.
1:15 AS McDAVID REBOUND, SCORE!
ZONE.
IN FRONT OF THE NET.
EVENTUALLY THEY'RE ABLE TO POUND
IT HOME AS
BY SHORE.
KANE FOR THE HAWKS.
OFF T
TARGET HAGEL.
MOVIE
THTH
DIDN'T COME BACK TO THE BENCH,
BUT KEEP AN EYE TOR.
DeBRINCAT IS NOT ONLY OKAY,
BUT ON THE IT BACK.
GREAT MOVEMENT AGAIN BY THE
HAHAE.
THE POWER PLAYS ARE A COMBINED
THREE FOR SIX MONTHTHF A HALF S,
HALF PASS.
HOPING FOR A GOOD RICOCHET. ABO4
HOURS IN THIS BUILDING. OKAY, YO
GET ME?
WE'LL GET IT BACK TO THE
REBOUND REVERSED BY CALEB JONES
OVER TO CONNOR MURPHY.